in an open letter to Librarians former
president Barack Obama spoke out against
the quote profoundly misguided book bans
in school libraries so the former
president wrote an open letter to
American Librarians and he appears in a
tick tock video decrying right-wing
censorship push now I've mentioned this
before all of the rhetoric you're
hearing about right wing censorship in
book bands is basically the left
complaining about the fact that
conservative parents have said that
pornographic material cannot and should
not be shown to children in public
schools and by the way even the the
articles that claim to be sympathetic to
this position that these are book bands
acknowledge that this is a movement
which is being led by parents parents
are the ones saying do not show this
content to my children it is not
right-wing special interest group saying
if you show this book to Children it
will expand their minds and it will it
will reduce our control over the
hegemonic narrative it is literally
parents saying don't show porn to our
children and about books that they are
defending are pornographic and have
pornographic content in them so uh in
the letter Barack Obama called it uh
profoundly misguided he said that books
including controversial books shaped his
life Barack I hope these kinds of books
are not the ones that shaped your life
he said it's no coincidence that these
banned books are often written by or
feature people of color indigenous
people and members of the lgbtq
community interesting is he alleging
that there are books being banned
because there are indigenous or black
people in them it's the most ridiculous
thing I've heard in my life
he's alleging but this this part here is
operative right this is the key the
lgbtq plus Community I agree Brock it is
kind of a weird coincidence that all of
the books that are being banned because
they have pornographic content in them
are being supported by the LGBT
community and your party maybe don't own
that so loudly what do you guys think I
think one thing that interesting is a
lot of these books and I've spoken to
moms for Liberty about this and about
the different books and different moms
who are like you know we don't want
genderqueer we don't want flamer we
don't want a lot of these books a lot of
them are actually graphic novels and I
wonder if it would be if anyone would
even notice if they were not graphic
novels because that's where you see this
you see you know uh lesbians fellating a
strap-on and gender queer and that's
certainly not something that you would
want in schools and I think a lot of
what is being missed is that it's not
that people are asking for books to be
banned they're asking for
age-appropriate material to be made
available to students you know
genderqueer has no business being taught
when I I bought this book myself we have
it here on the table I bought this book
myself to check it out and to say to see
what it was really about and even worse
than some of the images what I thought
was the most shocking was that the main
character
who had been raised in a very weird
situation
um grows up to decide to be non-binary
and the book ends right as she is
deciding to come out to the Middle
School class and I'm thinking that's
even more Insidious why do people feel
the need to why do teachers feel the
need to express their personal sexual
preferences orientations and you know
gender expression to their students I
find that so bizarre yeah you know I
don't remember uh I remember some of my
teachers were married but I don't
remember anything about them no I had
one fourth grade teacher who brought us
all over to her house Mrs Fife and I
remember even thinking at the time like
this is weird why are we at Mrs fife's
house yeah like this is very bizarre I
want to return to the time where like
when you saw your teacher in the grocery
store you were like you exist outside
school yeah exactly
and it's not because they're not human
and have their own lives and can do
whatever it's just because that's the
setting in which children know them like
I want them to feel like there is a a
certain relationship in school and I
don't like the idea that you would blur
the lines for your own emotional
gratification right the other thing too
isn't it oh I'm sorry oh I was just
gonna say like the pope had this
interesting comment on uh people having
dogs and I'm going to misquote it I know
there are instead of children yeah yeah
he was saying like the reason one of his
base quotes one of the reasons you like
uh people have dogs is because there's
less emotional work in this relationship
uh than having children and I think
there is something similar that's
happening here where it's like I
specifically want children to be like
wow we love you anyway whoever you are
because children are innocent and when
you feel like you have gotten
gratification from them you know it
there's some sort of secure trapped
audience effect there and I think that
should be also these are teachers who
never properly grew up you know they are
that's a huge part of it are these the
role models yeah I mean
when I was a kid which wasn't that long
ago but when I was a kid you didn't even
know your teacher's first name the idea
that your teacher is telling you about
all the perverse sexual things they're
doing behind the scenes is totally
insane but we know why it's happening
right this is grooming they want
children to be exposed to their perverse
lifestyle choices because grooming is
essentially a kind of perverse exposure
therapy people intuitively recoil at
perversion and degeneracy and so if you
keep putting it in front of the child
the idea is you will slowly chip away at
their intuitive sense that this is wrong
that's a huge deal too like when you
take a kid to drag Story Hour right like
if you do that there are kids you can
see in videos of this who recoil and the
moms are like and it's always moms the
moms they Gaslight them they Gaslight
them into thinking it's good totally
fine that's totally fine or the
Washington Post article by a mom who was
saying that she was taking her kid to
the pride parade and wanted the kid to
see Kink and to normalize Kink and or
the sex ed glasses that emphasize
pleasure in second grade and start
teaching kids there's no reason for a
sexy class in second grade period but
there's there's something more to this
too which I also find a little
disturbing which is uh I'm just sort of
expressing this for the first time so if
I screw it up you know you'll refine it
later I'll refine it later but the idea
is that
um if you're a kid why do you want all
of this stuff to come from authority
figures you know why do you why are
authority figures getting involved in
what essentially should be a kid's
private emotional life do you know what
I mean like I had this professor in
college uh Danny Kaiser
um and we were studying James Joyce and
Marcel proust in his class and the first
day of class he said I don't know why
you guys want me to teach you Joyce
when I was your age Joyce was mine I
didn't want anyone to teach it to me it
was for me I wanted to learn about it
myself and he said the same thing about
folk music he was way older than us
obviously but I think to a certain
extent like when I wanted to read weird
books when I was in high school which
you know like I was a weird curious kid
I read a lot of weird books I went and
found them for myself I didn't want
anyone to teach me anything I didn't
want anyone to teach me poetry I didn't
really want people to teach me Kafka I
wanted to read those things myself do
you know what I mean and so you have
these people who are not just
infiltrating the educational system and
infiltrating that but they're
infiltrating the private thoughts of
these kids who should be if they're
going to be thinking about these things
that should be their own private
thoughts to a certain extent it
shouldn't be involved with adults with
their parents at the very or they're you
know talk to your parents for sure but
like the infiltration of adults into
children's private lives is really
massive yeah and this is something I
also want to mention that came from one
of the articles I was reading about this
the ala has found that in U.S Public
Schools last year a record 2571 unique
titles were targeted for censorship
often led by parent groups oh no a 38
increase from the eight well eighteen
hundred unique titles Target for
censorship in 2021. now they're saying
that is if that's an indication that our
laws are becoming more Draconian we're
trying to prevent kids from seeing this
literature firstly this is happening
this kind of pornographic content is
being placed into public schools and
public school libraries at a much higher
rate than it was in the past so it makes
sense that you'd be seeing more people
trying to remove them I think parents
are also finally starting to wake up to
this stuff being in the libraries at
their kids schools or being taught in
their classrooms so it makes sense that
they'd stand up and say something but
again the article here acknowledges that
this is led by parent groups who are
saying stop showing this stuff to our
children and also this idea that there's
such a thing as being too selective
about what you're allowing your child to
be exposed to when they're off at a
school where you have no oversight over
them through the course of the day other
than the standards that you've gotten
the school to agree to is Total Insanity
it is a good thing that parents are
becoming more concerned with what their
kids are looking at in schools the fact
that you try to frame that is something
that I see these numbers and I go good
more parents are involved more parents
care about what their kids are reading
in their Ideal World the parents sit
back and say show whatever you want to
my kids I don't care now I happen to
disagree with that which is why I think
the fact that 2500 different titles are
being pulled out of public schools and
they're being told you can't show these
to our children is good because if
parents don't want their kids seeing
that stuff then the kids shouldn't be
looking at it well here's the other
thing though a lot of times it's really
hard to get the curriculum I don't know
if you guys are aware of this no I have
tried to and you know at the schools my
son has gone to not the Lutheran School
that he went to for a while that was
very easy but so much of the curriculum
is not on in books they don't send home
textbooks if the kids do worksheets the
worksheets stay at school that's a huge
thing so covid really opened people's
minds to this that's where I started to
really see what was going on at the
school in terms of like weird racial
education and whatever else so that is I
think one of the biggest uh upsides of
the pandemic that's where mobs for
Liberty came in they were like
vaccine mandates no masking no wait and
all these books all of this stuff that
you guys are looking at all of this
curriculum no and there was even a
situation where I think it was in Chico
California it was the Chico School
District anyway it's been on my list I
haven't been able to write about it I've
wanted to for a couple of days anyway a
parent was a mom was denied
the ability to look at the curriculum of
the school was told outright that she
couldn't see it and a lot of school
districts what they do is they say that
the material is copyrighted so they
can't send it home
and they keep the stuff from the parents
so the more they keep the stuff from the
parents the more angry parents are going
to get I know I was at Mom's for Liberty
The Summit in Philadelphia
a couple of weeks ago and when I was
talking to the moms about what was going
on they were really insistent you know
that they wanted to see what was going
on in the schools and they wanted to be
a part of it I will just say though did
you guys see what Barack Obama's
half-brother said about the list yeah no
he deleted the Tweet but he said this
man is definitely gay
um about Barack yeah dude Barack kills
him a lot you gotta eat more green
vegetables man your hair's too white I
love you brother
Ian's a dietary expert uh ever since
started bulking up for this music video
but I'm not against it I'm not against
it all of your comments just make me
return to the refrain only groomers ask
you to keep things from your parents
exactly exactly it is weird to me that
their position would be well don't talk
we can't show you like there shouldn't
be secrets between parents and children
obviously over time children develop
Independence and things like that but
like the school should be able to be
like no your knowledge it's just for me
and our your kids to look at right and
that is what that is what they do and
not only rumors you really cannot get
this material thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time